la russa camila válida puedes seguir
participando en los juegos olímpicos de
invierno de beijing juan el superbowl me
quito horas de sueño nosotros madrugamos
mucho pero lo disfruté comenzamos eso sí
hablando de otras noticias como decía
raúl caminaba lieva tiene vía libre para
continuar compitiendo en beijing 2022 y
participar es participar este martes en
la prueba individual de patinaje el
tribunal del tribunal de arbitraje
deportivo el tas argumenta que al ser
menor de 16 años y allí tiene 15 cuenta
con un estatus de persona protegida bajo
las reglas internacionales antidopaje y
suspenderla le causaría un daño
irreparable dicen el tasa en reconoce
que hay una importante cuestión ex
temporal en la notificación del cierre
positivo recordemos que la prueba se le
hizo el 25 de diciembre y el resultado
se entregó apenas la semana pasada en
medio de los juegos hay que resaltar que
este tribunal sólo abordó la cuestión de
si camila podría seguir participando en
beijing el tema de fondo su dopaje queda
ahora en manos de la agencia al rus
antidopaje bajo posterior revisión de la
agencia mundial antidopaje escuchemos
cuál fue la explicación del tribunal de
arbitraje deportivo
el panel consideró fundamental principio
fernet ever verbel home and related el
panel consideró los principios
fundamentales de equidad daño
irreparable y el relativo equilibrio de
intereses entre los solicitantes y la
atleta que no dio positivo durante los
juegos olímpicos de beijing pero que aún
está sujeta a un procedimiento
disciplinario por los méritos después de
su prueba antidopaje positiva realizada
en diciembre de 2021 en particular el
panel consideró que impedir que la
atleta compitan dos juegos le causaría
un daño irreparable en esas
circunstancias
por ende ser constantes al respecto el
comité olímpico internacional acordó que
no habrá ceremonia entrega de medallas
para la prueba de patinaje en equipos
por la en la que participó camila oliva
y donde ganó el oro además si ya termina
en puestos de podio en la prueba
individual tampoco habrá ceremonia de
hecho el coi pide que se incluya una
patinadora además en este programa por
razones de justicia en esa prueba por
equipos en donde camila ganó y además
con una participación muy buena primera
mujer que consiguió un salto cuádruple
plata fue eeuu bronce y japón y canadá
terminó cuarta